they saw us Kevin here with a perfect
explanation for a 56 reduction in
violent crime between 1992 and 2002 a
study of Uniform Crime reporting data
found that removing lead from gasoline
over a decade before reduced lead's
detrimental effects on children's
developing brains so when they grew up
they committed less crime makes sense
right wrong using the Bureau of Justice
statistics National Crime victimization
survey data showed that leaded gasoline
had no effect at all on violent crime
rates it wasn't 56 it was zero percent
two data sets led to two completely
opposite conclusions because measuring
social phenomena is hard and it's
actually a really new thing 200 years
ago no one even measured crime rates now
we measure everything the problem is
that most of our measurements are wrong
we've been counting people for a while
China had censuses over 4 000 years ago
the Romans conducted censuses for
Taxation and Military conscription
cancera in Latin literally means to tax
and William the Conqueror ordered the
Doomsday Book to be compiled in 1086 but
even then it was just counting people
property and farm animals there was
nothing about people's lives let alone
keeping track of what they did to harm
others democracy had matured by the 5th
Century BC in Athens but demography
didn't exist until the 1600s English
haberdasher John Grant analyzed the
weekly bills of mortality official lists
of births deaths and causes of death to
better understand life in the 1660s
170 years later Andre Michelle Gary
changed everything his 1832 presentation
to the French Academy of Sciences to
detail the moral statistics of France
assaults murders suicides Gary tracked
them all revealing that their rates
differed throughout France and by age
sex race and other General demographics
we still use there were some odd
findings like literacy rates weren't
correlated with crimes against people
while higher literacy rates were
correlated with crimes against property
apparently reading makes you break
things and math finally collided with
morality the social statistics era
boomed some people wanted to lock up
more criminals others wanted to spend
more money on Social Services they
thought would reduce crime does this
sound familiar Gary proclaimed we are
forced to recognize that the facts of
the moral order are subject like those
of the physical order to invariable laws
the truth is that crime statistics are
highly variable
highly do you have or no children would
you like to mold a young mathematical
mind in the image of Vsauce you may have
heard that male science is now part of
our curiosity box family well this is
what I've been working on math can feel
like it's mostly in your mind but it's
actually all around us and now I'm
putting it in the next generation's
hands with the world's first math
experiments subscription box each month
kids get new math projects with
step-by-step video instructions and
lessons from me in the app this level of
beauty and precision would be impossible
to draw by hand and all it takes is a
few smartly constructed gears they'll
build a range of Hands-On projects that
introduce high-level Concepts in math
engineering and the human experiences
behind them this is the gift to give a
kid in your life where you want to solve
the problems of tomorrow go to
melscience.com
Evan you will see me literally on the
webpage this is my math box it's going
to be awesome get 50 off your first box
with code Kevin only available in the US
for now get math out of their heads and
into their hands link down in the
description below we'll get back to the
video but uh remember math box go ahead
get the math box okay the first problem
is uniformity in police forces and data
collection and in laws cool what does
that mean here's an example let's say
the rate of assault annually is 1 655
per 100 000 in Scotland 23 in India and
291 in Estonia is a Scottish guy just 70
times more likely to punch you in the
face than an Indian are estonians
relatively well behaved let's analyze
the data Scotland has had a
well-publicized alcoholism epidemic and
alcohol is a frequent component of
assaults Scotland consumes 9.4 liters of
pure alcohol per adult every year and
India consumes just 5.7 liters so it
would make sense that Scotland would
have a lot more assaults which was a
major argument by the teetotaler
movement and prohibition but Estonia
consumes 11.6 liters per adult annually
and their assault numbers are way lower
than Scotland's so it's more complex
than this maybe it's more police
Scotland has 318 per 100 000 residents
India has just 152 so less policing
might mean fewer reported crimes is it
just easier to get caught and held
responsible in Scotland Estonia has 300
136 police per 100
000 which is a little more than Scotland
so does that additional 5.6 percent of
police presence make a huge difference
in deterring assaults I doubt it this
has to be a question of laws maybe
Scotland's assault laws are so loosely
defined that their rate is artificially
inflated well no Scottish law considers
assault to be an act that causes bodily
harm or leads one to think bodily harm
is imminent which is pretty sensible are
India's definitions of assault so
narrowly defined and severely restricted
that hardly anything qualifies it's
actually the complete opposite section
351 of the Indian Penal Code has such a
broad definition that it includes
shaking your fist in a threatening
manner
so what's the the answer here do the
Scottish just report everything to the
police do Indians handle fist-shaking
problems themselves so police never even
know about the crimes maybe Estonia is
obsessive about crime tracking and the
Indians are a decade behind in their
paperwork
who knows this is the problem with moral
statistics what looks like an Apples to
Apples comparison can be apples to
aardvarks the second problem is data can
change over time in Boston the Cambridge
Somerville Youth Study was conducted in
1945 it went like this 253 pairs of boys
were matched by age IQ and a range of
social factors researchers flipped a
coin to see which of the two would
receive counseling tutoring for school
and even a summer camp getaway the idea
was that delivering all those social
supports would improve their life's
outcomes the research showed it didn't
really do anything then 30 years later a
researcher followed up on the lives of
all the boys involved in the study and
found that the ones who received
counseling committed more crime and had
higher rates of alcoholism and mental
illness which is pretty weird the third
problem is money you've got to show
results to keep keep your jobs and your
funding that perverse incentive seems to
have led the LAPD to misclassify 1 200
violent crimes as minor offenses in 2012
to 2013 to reduce its crime rate on
paper that same year the Chicago Police
Department erased murders from official
crime statistics once they realized they
wouldn't be able to solve them in 1946
criminology Professor Paul toppin wrote
that we study the criminals convicted by
the courts and not the real criminal at
all but an insignificant proportion of
non-representative and stupid
unfortunates who happen to become
enmeshed in technical legal difficulties
and that's the fourth problem a
significant portion of crimes go
unreported and many of the major
criminals Go free while their foot
soldiers get caught but even when we
know a crime has happened and who's
responsible we'd struggle to know why is
their correlation is their causation
does a decrease in crime reflect a new
law being effective or better policing
or is it a statistical Mirage caused by
a regression to the mean or some social
Factor no one has even considered and
what are the unintended consequences of
our interventions the fifth problem is
that the media reports the numbers it's
got and sometimes the numbers it's
incentivized to report which can lead to
Media generated crime waves and moral
panics crime rates affect property
values where people choose to live what
schools their kids attend they determine
where we as a society assign blame and
they can infect our social attitudes our
perception of crime sometimes strong
sometimes too light informs who we elect
to lead and write laws for towns cities
states and Nations
the final problem
is you
did you ever do something bad as a kid
and when your mom asks you why did you
do it you said
I don't know and you really truly did
not know it's the same with criminology
there's such a complex relationship of
psychological biological social
emotional and economic factors that even
when it's happening in our own heads we
usually can't make any sense of it
so if we can't trust the numbers and we
can't trust ourselves what are we left
with knowing that we don't know
is probably a good place to start and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]